thing and he press this you told to me
that's my correct
you don't have to be
actually I'll stand up
right
there is no
oh that I think yes oh yeah yeah can you
hear me
you must be wait is it this one
can you hear me now no is it this one
can you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just yeah yeah okay I try not to
break anything I said you won't break
that stand I'd be very impressed
actually if you break that stone no
challenge me okay okay let's try that
again how do I take one of these things
off
[Music]
I fluffed it again
[Music]
it's getting better yeah the reason you
never hear extraneous noises on
recordings is because they would move
like and breaths as well every little
breath they chop out it makes it really
clear
yeah like you can edit and replace
things out I am 5 foot no I go from lack
of skin fighting what's within a smile
through gritted te like you why he here
with me and though it's been so many
years I'm still trapped beneath my fear
oh it's the curse came in like half I
see the rest ok I was like I okay I'll
carry on I want to see what you sent me
last night was kind of how I was
envisioning it I couldn't see it like
that but I mean I wanted something more
abstract so yeah something that well the
chorus interestingly enough this is
gonna make no sense to me
you wrote a chord progression on the
double harmonic scale which is an
incredibly exotic scale used in
Bulgarian gypsy music
yeah so it's a really hard it's very ya
know it's been so many hands I'm still
trapped beneath my fears and if you
change your mind and stay meet me behind
my prey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes yes
[Music]
[Music]